Fun really isn't something one considers we balance the universe
-but this
does for a smile on my face
Hey everybody so you requested a new infinity war video so they've actually started filming Avengers for now would they still haven't confirmed the
But we'll talk about that because remember there was all that Zoe Saldana business earlier this year where she referred to it as
Gauntlet as in the Infinity Gauntlet. Can you tell us if you're in infinity war in the middle of it?
I think that the Guardians just shocked their part when it comes to
Infinity Wars like the first part and we all have to go back for gauntlets later this year
But if you are finding me for the first time I do Marvel videos every week be sure to subscribe to get everything in there
Will be new giveaway stuff at the end of the video so the big thing here is that?
Vision is on set for infinity war looking exactly the same way he does in all the movies
Meaning that he still has the Infinity gem in his forehead
Now if you're not a big comic book reader in the comics the gem in his forehead is called the Sun stone
It's more like a solar battery. It just helps charge him but in the movies
He has the Infinity gem Thanos needs that to finish the Infinity Gauntlet
So the minute they announced that vision would have the Infinity gem in his forehead way back during age of Ultron people were like ooh
R.i.p
vision well
I guess his days are numbered because Thanos is gonna need that gem and will even be able to exist as a normal person after
That like will Ultron's programming inside of him reassert itself. What's gonna happen
There's just so many questions and even though they're changing the comics a lot
He effectively gets ripped to pieces in the comics
But the vision character during the comic book version of the story just isn't that big compared to the other characters like dr.
Strange is much bigger. There's gonna be a whole lot of changes so once they start dropping the official trailers
We can start pointing to things like oh hey dope this is obviously gonna be Spider Man's iron spider suit his big Avengers upgrade
We've seen the footage that they've already dropped
I've already done a couple trailer videos for the d23 in the Comic Con footage
So I'll link those at the end of this
But in those you seethe annos wielding a partially assembled
Infinity Gauntlet, so he has the gauntlet, and he has a couple of the gems in it he doesn't have all of them
He wields the gauntlet grabbing a I hate chunk of moon and rips it away from the planetoid and throws it at them
So we're talking Galactus level power
We have since met the black order they've introduced the children of Thanos as they're calling them in the movies in the comics
They're just his followers
They're just his elite generals
But the movies making it more like they're his children
In the way that Kimora and nebula are his children so like during guardians of the galaxy they talk about how they used to fight
each other
Every time my sister prevailed
My father would replace a piece of me with machinery like maybe if I enhance you you won't be so weak
So he's done that to all these people and they posted a behind-the-scenes video with them wearing their old costumes
So there's gonna be flashbacks that'll explain what their upbringing was like when Gamora was still training with Thanos
So it'll probably just provide some
Context for the evil Avengers that he forms around him like you have the good Avengers that we've seen in all these other movies now
Thanos has his own version of the Dark Avengers that he's gonna throw at them
But it looks like it's gonna be Proxima midnight or even Corvus glaive
That's gonna come for vision to take the gem and bring it back to Thanos
But a lot of people were watching this happen as it was playing out like you see vision looking like he's a human so it
Looks as they just play with their comic book relationship like vision can make himself look like whatever he wants to so he's gonna be
morphing into Paul Bettany
Probably just to bridge the gap and make their relationship more possible before he gets his ass handed to him
But if you haven't seen the infinity war footage
They have part of that fight in there you see a shot of Captain America holding Proxima midnight
Spear so at some point some of the Avengers come to help him out so if there was any doubt before now it seems like
It's confirmed that Avengers 4 will be the continuation of the Infinity Gauntlet comic book storyline
Where as infinity war the movie is gonna be more like the Thanos quest comic book storyline?
So that's just the story that came right before the Infinity Gauntlet storyline in the comics so when Zoe Saldana was like
Mistakenly saying oh, yeah, we go back to film gauntlet the fourth movie later this year
she was talking about the
storyline for
The movie and that might have just been the working title for the movie because then supposedly James Gunn came out after that and was
Like that's not what the movies that's not called Infinity Gauntlet
So we can all theory craft about what they'll call the movie if they're doing the Infinity Gauntlet storyline
But I wouldn't be surprised if it has infinity somewhere in the title Avengers infinity
Dot dot dot but I still think that they'll try to differentiate in some way from
Infinity war for the casual movie-going audience that doesn't distinguish between a lot of big comic book
storylines like if you saw two things on a shelf saying
Infinity war and Infinity Gauntlet you probably a little more confused
So they might wind up opting for a title that's a little more distinct from infinity war, but I really do
Hope they just call it Infinity Gauntlet because that sounds like what the movie is going to be
The cast has been really funny about it. This is the video they dropped right after they posted all this footage
It was like goosebumps, and you see goosebumps and my characters you know
We first saw it a couple of months ago when we started working on it today to unveil it
and we had only you know been filming for a handful of months at that point and
There is something visceral when you see the Avengers and the guardians and Doctor Strange and Black Panther and spider-man
all together
You just can't you can't help it, and that was the idea today was to bring that cast out
They were geeking out as much as the audience was
mom was
So I know all of you are asking
When are they gonna drop that first infinity war trailer remember Thor comes out that first weekend in November?
That's probably when they're going to drop it
If not a little bit before then usually it's the same week as that movie comes out because they'll probably roll the trailer in front
Of the movie in movies typically don't premiere til Thursday Friday night
But most of you have probably figured out that they drop all the biggest trailers on Tuesdays
So if you have anything going on that week the Thor's coming out I would clear your schedule
Just in case that infinity war footage drops believe all your Avengers video requests in the comments below
I'm probably gonna do a spider-man video soon for his iron spider suit
That's what I'm calling it now, but technically it's really just an upgraded Avengers
Level suit like it'll be so badass
That it makes the stark tech suit that he had during homecoming seem like second grade
Which I think is holy because the whole thing about homecoming is that that suit was super Opie like it was so
Amazing that he could barely figure it out without nedley's help hacking into it
Congratulations to the new Thor ticket giveaway winner Patti the Pug
Please private message me on the back end of my channel so I can get your contact details
There's a new round in this video all you have to do to enter just be a subscriber leave a Marvel related comment
I'll announce a winner when I post a new Marvel video
But there's a new flash to post this weekend some new Rick and Morty so while you wait for everything click here for that
Infinity war video that I was talking about and you can click here for brand new Rick and Morty
Thank you so much for watching. Everybody stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight